I don't really don't III think I think
the great the Great is one of the
greatest man on the Supreme Court ever
was Thurgood Marshall and I think he
said he just wanted two men said he did
his best I think that's what most people
would like you do your best and that's a
and do if you you know and that's it you
do have the job you do your best you
take other people into account you try
to figure out and think about what the
what what you're doing will mean for
people and and then you try to do this
as as well as you major consequences
think of Brown versus Board of Education
which turned the nation away from
segregation and really started to make
the Constitution mean what it says in my
opinion certainly you don't know what
will have consequences you can't you
don't know it's I think history looks
back and it's sort of like the stock
market my view of history which is not
very sophisticated then the stock market
it goes up or it goes down and then the
experts tell you the next day why you
should have known the previous day of
course they don't all they do is a
thousand things happen and they pick out
what's significant well the historians
look back and they say of course this
would have happened because these
earlier things happened but they know
what happened and they're looking to see
what's significant and we're operating
in a world where we'll decide things and
we don't know precisely what will happen
in the future so what we do is we do our
best on each case if a district judge is
deciding a case of two people in front
of him that case is tremendously
consequential for those two people and a
district judge at the trial level will
take that with tremendous seriousness
because it matters to those people it
might be a matter of prison it might be
a matter of whether one is bankrupt or
not
might be a matter of family there are
lots of things that matter now every
judge at every level takes the job
seriously and that I think is the most a
person in my position can do you can do
your best that's Yogi Berra I never make
predictions you know he says the
particular we know is Casey Stengel I
never make predictions particularly not
about the future but God you don't know
I don't know I know that the most
important thing as you probably gathered
from the tenor of the conversation is as
a judge to get people to focus on the
particular cases to make certain that
the court is not a political institution
to make certain as best I can that
people understand what we do to make
certain that we do our job that's the
primary thing so that's that so you say
one thing I think I got that from my
father used to say you know do your job
as well as you can by the way people
notice you might get a better job but if
you if they don't notice you'll still
have the gratification of having done
your job fairly well he's always be free
always do that usually once or twice in
a year some just someone will read a
dissent from a badge and it's typically
a dissent in a case that we think has
some importance and that we think the
dissent dissenters usually think is very
wrongly decided the normal attitude when
you write a dissent is is how right I am
you know I mean that's human nature but
but there have been more than usual and
I think what the dissenters have been
saying in their two cents is we think
they're quite a few decisions with which
we strongly disagree
six cases out of the eight in a year I
counted it was about two or three years
ago six out of the 80 involved questions
of foreign law and they weren't these
questions you'll see in the newspaper
like Guantanamo which is an integral
good the Geneva Conventions they were
questioned such as a plaintiff in
Ecuador who sold vitamins A vitamin
distributor wanted to sue a vitamin
manufacturer in Holland and saying he
was a member of a cartel and there was
an American member too and he wanted to
bring his lawsuit in the United States
an antitrust suit can he do it does the
law allow him to sue here that's a very
hard question and an important question
in the antitrust area we had mrs.
Altmann mrs. Altmann who wanted the
Klimt paintings she said that the Nazis
had taken the Klimt paintings from her
aunt she sued to get them back the
Austrian museum said we're part of the
government we have sovereign immunity
did they or didn't they have sovereign
immunity that came to the court I found
an answer to that question or a help in
an answer in a court of appeals decision
in Paris France what we had the trucks
coming in from Mexico the trucks who are
part of NAFTA selling goods in the
United States and there were there was a
law that some were trying to invoke to
keep them out and NAFTA seemed to
trumpet did it or did it not terribly
important we had cases involving the
Warsaw convention on airline liability
we had cases of tort law in 17 something
or other Congress passed a statute that
allows a person injured by a violation
of international law to recover damages
well that was stopped that's because of
pirates see they were the pirate
kidnapped you you could get damages if
you found the pirate even if you're from
Venezuela and even if the pirate is from
Ecuador and you're in the United States
you consume if you can find in Pirates
wherever they are or who are the Pirates
today are they the dictators in Paraguay
that was a question
say what about end so that these
questions all involve if you're going to
decide them correctly they involve
knowing something about the law of other
nations they involve knowing something
about international law comedy how these
things work so the law schools have to
teach it because I don't know all those
things I have to look them up how do I
look them up the lawyers have to lead me
to the right sources the lawyers have to
tell me about them and the lawyers won't
know about them unless they're taught in
the law schools there for more and more
you're finding in law schools in normal
courses segments of the courses where
they'll bring in what's happening
elsewhere in the world that's a very
good thing and that's part of what i
mean by this loom that's knitting I
don't know I don't know you don't
necessarily have to have an
international court to have an
integrated law we have an integrated
commercial law in the United States in
all 50 states but the reason is that all
50 states have adopted the Uniform
Commercial Code which as was originally
proposed probably and sold by the
uniform law commissioners the univ as i
mentioned them before they went from
state to state so you didn't have to
have some hierarchical organization to
get that done so whether there will be
more or not of international courts I
can't be sure I'm reasonably certain
they'll be specialized international
courts there are specialized courts as
part of the World Trade Organization
their specialized courts we have them as
part of NAFTA there are specialized
courts I think in in respect to the
Canadian certain treaties we've entered
into commercial treaties with Canada
there as as as there's more
international commerce there will be
more international specialized courts
whether they'll be at international
penal court or not i think a lot depends
on how well does when done
the law has a way of resolving
jurisdictional questions I mean their
rules for resolving jurisdictional
questions there aren't usually fights
about it there could be but not usually
and interestingly enough for example I
was looking at a decision that the
European Court in Luxembourg which is
the European Union court was a maid and
and in certain respects the law of
Europe was trumped by the law of the the
WTO I think well they don't mind you
know the judges don't mind that's fine
they say that's there this is the law
under the rules of conflicts that
governs then they'll apply it they'll
apply whatever law is required to be
applied by the law the law of laws let's
see what a complicated subject law